exclusive interview with Uber CEO his
name is Dara cosmashahi now the company
announced several updates and new
features just yesterday they include
rides that are tailored specifically for
teenagers okay and the option for a car
seat if you're traveling with a younger
child of that there's also a new group
grocery feature that's good for
splitting the bill you're going to like
this too and for the list tech savvy of
you out there in the audience you can
call to order your ride on the phone
call on the phone okay yep call on the
phone Dara cosmashaw he joins us at the
table good to see you Mr badass
a lot of these changes are very exciting
what are you most excited about I
personally am most excited about the
Uber teen accounts for parents I'm uh
I've got four kids yes and sometimes on
the weekend I'm spending more time
driving them around than parenting them
yes so this is an account that parents
can create for their teens they can
invite teens to the count and it's got
safety built in look at that from the
start to the Finish only our best
drivers can't you Dara
it's built into the feature so first of
all we get we get the best drivers who
are the most experienced who have the
best ratings
um at the beginning of the ride there's
a pin code that the teen has and the
driver has they've got a match so that
you make sure you're in the right car
uh no there's the same same price
absolutely it's on your credit card so
you've got to pay for your team yeah
that's that's uh part of the deal
there's an audio recording feature yes
so what happens is you track the rod so
you can see the pickup drop off and
there's an audio recording feature that
is totally private it's encrypted it's
on the phone but if something happens
and the driver and the team knows that
you know if something happens there's
going to be an audio recording that
lessens the chance of anything bad
that's so good and what about I heard a
feature for grandparents do grandparents
need a special feature you know like
wait a second if they want a special
feature there are some grandparents who
are very comfortable you know using apps
Etc but there's some grandparents
they're less comfortable using smart
you know my mother-in-law might be such
a grandparent and so I'm I'm her Uber
dispatcher myself and my wife Sarah the
Uber dispatchers so call you and she'll
call me and you know we'll get it Uber
for her
yeah exactly like I'm the dispatcher so
now you can call 1-833 use Uber I think
and you can either get On Demand or it
can be a reservation as well we have a
reserve feature so you can get an Uber
if you go to an airport or going to
dinner yes and you can call someone and
we'll make it happen can I do that as a
non-grandparent just for a retro feel
you know if you're feeling in the 80s
yeah absolutely if you want to go back
in time you can do it too uh not wanting
to go back in time to a time of high
inflation like we have now but it's been
happening people are worried about the
cost of everyday items they're worried
about the economy and one thing that
could completely topple the economy are
is the debt ceiling Fiasco going on
right now in Washington any advice right
now for our leaders in DC about getting
a deal done get together have real
conversations instead of trying to play
politics because this is serious this
affects everyone's lives it's not time
to play politics it's time to get it
done are you worried about a recession
uh I'm I wouldn't say worried it's gonna
happen I think based on everything that
we see but we're hoping that it will be
quick uh and it won't be too tough uh
and in the meantime as Uber we're going
to do what we're doing which is get your
transportation get you to places get
your food get you what you mean okay
from uh inflation to tip flation a lot
of drivers rely on tips and just for
clarity uh 100 of the tips go to the
drivers 100 go to the drivers 100 uh but
a minority only uh tip we found that
kind of strong we've got a majority
you're the majority that we love so when
you when people are ordering food part
of the habits as you tip so the majority
of food orders uh tip on rides the
minority tip but but I'll tell you I've
been driving myself as a Uber driver and
I've got a couple of cash tips so we
track tips that go through the app 100
goals cash tips are okay cash chips are
okay considered increasing the wages for
your drivers because they are relying so
much on tips that they might not get so
drivers generally driver earnings now if
you look at the last quarter we paid out
to drivers over 13 billion dollars it
was up 30 percent yarn year and drivers
on average in the U.S make 33 bucks an
hour uh utilized hour when they're being
called driving to pick you up or or
carrying you so the earnings are
actually quite good yeah uh compared to
history you know why I think it's hard
there because in the beginning we didn't
have to tip that was one of the
attractions of uber you just get out of
the car so I think when you're used to
getting something it's hard to make in
the beginning I didn't tip either I was
like
I'm gonna give you a star yeah yeah so
I'll give you a story yeah but then I
realized that actually didn't feel so
good after you realize how it works I
think the culture is changing you can
put in your tip up front so that it's
just as easy and you can adjust it you
know if the driver was excellent yeah
you can tip more what was your day
driver reading by the way my driver
rating is still five stars and I'm
hoping to keep it that way you know
the driver is excellent yes if the
driver does a great job then uh you can
express that on tip and we think that's
just great I wonder the people that gave
you a five did they know you were Dara I
wear I wear masks so I'm I'm not doing
it to get recognized I'm just going to
provide a service all right uh any plans
for integrating uh AI into oh that's a
good quote definitely so ai's been a big
part of our services you know the ETA
that you get six minutes five minutes
that's those are learning algorithms
that are estimating those times uh the
choices we show you whether it's a we
got taxi in New York or Uber black or
are you an uberX kind of a person all of
that is determined by AI now there's
this new generation of AI coming this
generative AI That's much more complex
and I think in a funny way AI is going
to allow Uber to be more human in our
interactions with you all of the
communications are going to be much more
personalized right now the
communications are standard and then you
know we'll put in a price there Etc
there's a there's a bit of
personalization the next generation of
AI is gonna is going to create a
personal relationship between Uber well
let's make sure that we did develop a
personal relationship that they don't
cancel on you no they're so frustrating
to order the car yes and two minutes out
and then it's gone
well what what we've done is
cancellations are much were much higher
in the past when driver didn't know
where you were going and the number one
feature that drivers asked us for is hey
what's The Upfront destination they
should know that yeah now in New York
City that's limited because of the laws
regarding fairs in New York city so New
York City we haven't been able to quite
extend that to drivers but in the rest
of the us where we can we show them up
from destinations that's the most common
reason for a cancellation yeah it's a
destination that that they didn't want
to go to so we're fixing that wherever
we can okay well we appreciate is there
anything else we can help you with uh
keep taking Uber no doubt about it thank
you so much for making the trip you've
got five stars on this visit by the way
I'm thinking that uh Uber black sweater
right now
oh I don't have my wallet so much